Redesigning has been characters
as someone who hasn't watched the show yet,
Vox is another
one I've been getting a ton of comments about.
He's very, very cool
and I love his voice so much,
but unfortunately that coolness doesn't
really translate through his design,
in my opinion.
The very first thing on my list to change was his hat,
which I'm sorry,
is too goofy looking for such a snarky character.
My first instinct was to give him V R.
Goggles because he's obsessed with new tech,
but after learning more about him,
that wouldn't make any sense for a TV anchor,
so I swapped it out for a futuristic headset instead.
Since Vox is Ellaster's foil in the show,
I wanted my redesigns to have something in common,
as my Ellaster's voice comes from the radio
in his chest.
My Vox's chest is an old fifties TV,
which used to be his head.
I'd like to think that
even though his face projects on the flat screen,
his consciousness will always be in the old TV
no matter how many upgrades he gives himself.
And he hates it.
As for his outfit n palette,
I mostly left the colors alone
because they're really sick,
but I did give him a less stereotypical has been outfit
and more obvious robotic parts.
And here's Vox!